the un general assembly's annual
session has got underway and it's
a special one not only is it marking
its 75th anniversary but this year
it will be virtual thanks to coronavirus
the world's diplomats
will be working from home yesterday
world leaders have often used the
general assembly podium
to air their
[Music]
a issues sometimes personal
and sometimes ideological
should not be called the security
council it should be called the terror
council
a grave for colonial slavery it should
be buried the deeper
the better and sometimes when over 10
000 people from over 190 countries meet
in one place
stuff happens didn't expect that
reaction but that's okay
and that non-mandatory limit for
speeches of 15 minutes
is often broken
[Music]
really broken
this year's speeches are pre-recorded
it's hard to imagine presidents and
prime ministers
sitting in front of zoo listening to
their counterparts droning on
and as it's 2020 the un's wi-fi
will probably stop working anyway